MEMBER PONTA NOTICES THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM THE SERGEANTS AT
ARMS WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER
AND BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA BAUER K.
HAN. BENNETT BERMAN. BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BRIAN BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES TEN CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM. DOLLY DALY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER ESTINA GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA GIPSON GREAT. GRAYSON
HOLDEN. IRWIN DURING JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY LEE
LEVINE. LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MOTOR CITY NAZARIAN WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUICKSILVER
RAMOS RIEZ THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SCIARRETTO SMITH
STONE TANG CALAVERAS. COULD WHAT
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN. IMAM USER. IN THE
NAME OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. OH LORD. GIVE
US A VOICE THAT YOU'RE JUST AS
BE HEARD AGAIN ON OUR- AND YOUR
GOODNESS BE REVEALED AND SIGNS
OF UNITY AND PEACE. MAY ALL THE
WORDS ECHOED IN THIS CHAMBER
TODAY SPRING FORTH FROM YOUR
LOVE PRESENT IN THE HEARTS OF
THIS NATION. LET YOUR TRUTH AND
YOUR BEAUTY BE OUR GUIDE. AS WE
GATHER TO SERVE THE COMMON GOOD
. WE ARE YOUR BLESSING NOW AND-
I MEAN. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PERKS SILVA AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE. PLEASE JOIN US AS WE
SALUTE OUR FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO FRIDAY SEPTEMBER TEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS UNLIMITED
LIVING THIRTY AM MODEL KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKING WHATEVER THIS
SIMPLY BECAUSE I GUESS REYES
MOVES AND MISTER FLOOR SECONDS
OF THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
. PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE. MOVING.
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. MAJORITY LEADER RACE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MODE SWITCHING DAVIES WHEN SALAS
AND BY ABOUT IS TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. RESEARCH ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY EIGHT THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS ARE GIVING A ONE DAY
NOTICE TO REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
ITEM ONE I'M SORRY I DIDN'T
EIGHT ELEVEN. EIGHTY SIX THIRTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND
ITEM EIGHTY TÍNH. AB TWELVE OH
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM.
PROPONENT I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
REMOVE ITEMS EIGHT TWENTY SIX OF
THE UNITED TO FILE AND ALLOW THE
PENDING FLOOR AMENDMENTS AT THE
DESK TO BE TAKEN UP TODAY
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. MR
FOR WHAT PURPOSE THE RIGHT PRICE
. LOCAL THANK YOU- THERE IS AN
OBJECTION TO THE. THERE'S AN
OBJECTION TO THE SUSPENSION OF
RULES MR FLOOR ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MAJORITY LEADER REYES IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THE ROOM MOTION
ALL THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE MISTER FLORES ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MISS. C. NG C. THE
NUMBERS MIXED RACE IS ASKING FOR
AN ITEM. MISTER IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE ON THE SUSPENSION OF THE
RULES. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLL EYES ARE FORTY TWO KNOWS
ARE FOURTEEN RULES ARE SUSPENDED. THAT'S RIGHT. PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WITHDRAW AB FOURTEEN TEN
RODRIGUEZ FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
ORDER THE BILL TO THE SECOND
READING FILE THE BILL IS NOT
FISCAL. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE. FILE ITEMS
ONE TO FORTY THREE SHALL BE
CONTINUED. FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR
SHALL BE CONTINUED. FILE ITEMS
FORTY FIVE AND FORTY SIX WILL
PASS AND RETAIN. WE WILL BRING
UP FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN THIS IS
AB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY
AN ACT RELATING TO YOUTH
ATHLETICS MR MCCARTY MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
A BILL TO WORK ON MAKING USE.
TACKLE FOOTBALL MORE SAFE IN
CALIFORNIA THE WHOLE STATE IS
RIVETED THIS WEEKEND TO WATCH
OUR L. A. RAMS THAT ARE
FOREIGNERS PLAY FOOTBALL IN THE
ROAD TO THE SUPER BOWL IN
INGLEWOOD IN A FEW WEEKS.
ANOTHER ISSUE OF IMPORTANCE TO
CALIFORNIA IS THE IMPACTS TO OUR
YOUNGEST KIDS IN TACKLE FOOTBALL
FRANKLY PARENTS ARE VOTING WITH
THEIR FEET. FLAG FOOTBALLMORE
NOW HAS MORE PARTICIPANTS THAN
YOUTH TACKLE FOOTBALL BUT TOO
OFTEN. THERE WE HAVE TRAGIC
INCIDENTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES FEW
WEEKS AGO ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS. A GREAT COLLEGE
ATHLETE LEGENDARY HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL PLAYER TOOK HIS OWN
LIFE. IN HIS SUICIDE NOTE HE
NOTICED THAT SOMETHING WAS WRONG
WE ASK THAT HIS BRAIN BE BUT
DON'T IT TO THE COULD.
CONCUSSION LEGACY FUND THE STUDY
HIS BRAIN IN THE IN THE BRAIN
BANK. THIS IS A KEY ISSUE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THERE'S
LOTS OF DEBATE. BUT WE WANT TO
SETTLE THE DEBATE NASCAR TOP
RESEARCHER IN CALIFORNIA DEALING
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH OUR SURGEON
GENERAL TO FURTHER STUDY THE
ISSUE. AND COME UP WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS WHAT WE SHOULD
DO WITH YOUTH TACKLE FOOTBALL IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WITH
THAT I ASK THE ARRIVAL THIS
MORNING THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
MCCARTY. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBER
WISHING TO. BE RECOGNIZED FOR
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. TIRED OF THE
- ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING CALIBER'S AS FIFTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE MEASURE IS PASSED.
YOU'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHT THIS IS AB EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CORK
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS DR QUIRKY ME OPEN.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AB EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN WILL ENSURE THAT THE
METALLIC FOIL BALLOONS ARE MADE
USING NEW METHODS THAT MAKE IT
SAFER FOR OUR POWER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PUBLIC SAFETY
. WORKING WITH THE BALLOON
COUNCIL AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
TO ENSURE THAT THE REQUIREMENTS
IMPOSED ON BALLOON MANUFACTURERS
ARE FEASIBLE THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR WORK SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE
MEASURE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ZERO ALL THOSE VOTE IT IS
TO MOVE. ALL THOSE THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLLING CALLIE THE
VOTES HIGHS FIFTY SIX KNOWS ZERO
MEASURES PASSED. NEXT WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE THIS IS AB NINE SEVENTY TWO
CORKERY ASSEMBLYBILL NINE
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS SOME THE RUMEN YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED MY EIGHTY
SEVEN THIRTY NEARLY CRAFTED BILL
TO PROHIBIT THE DISTRIBUTION OF
DEEPFAKES. AND OTHER MANIPULATED
MEDIA WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF AN
ELECTION. UNLESS THE IMAGE OR
RECORDING INCLUDED DISCLOSURE
STATING THAT IT IS MANIPULATED.
THE BILL PASSED ON A STRONG BY
PER. VOTE THIS BILL IS NINE
SEVEN TWO WOULD KEEP THE LAW
INTACT FROM FOUR YEARS. BY
EXTENDING THE CURRENT SUNSET.
DOING SO WILL PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS IN
THE COMING YEARS AS DEEPFAKE
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCES AND BECOMES
EVEN MORE MAINSTREAM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MR BERMAN. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS
OR DEBATE THE MEASURE THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. TIRED ALL
THOSE VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
THE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES HEISER
FORTY SIX KNOWS OR THREE THE
MEASURES PASSED. MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY HOUSE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY EIGHT KERKORIAN. HOUSE
RESOLUTION SEVEN DAY BY SIMPLY
MEMBERS OF OUR QUE HAN AND
OTHERS IT RELATIVE TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE SOME OF
OUR CAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO COMMEMORATE THE FORTY
NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE SEMINAL
CASE ROE V. WADE. ROVI WADE
GRANTED WOMEN THE RIGHT TO
PRIVACY. THE RIGHT TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT HER OWN BODY. IT
ON. THE FACT THAT WOMEN ROTONDA
HUMAN BEINGS WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE AND ABILITY TO
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES. WHEN AND
IF THEY SHOULD GET REMAIN
PREGNANT. AND TODAY AS WE HONOR
THE FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THIS IMPORTANT CASE. WE MUST
REFLECT ON WHAT THE FUTURE MAY
HOLD. WE STAND AT THE PRECIPICE
OF THE MOMENT WHEN ROE V. WADE
MAY NO LONGER BE INTACT. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALONE A
HUNDRED SIX ABORTION
RESTRICTIONS HAVE BEEN ENACTED
IN NINETEEN STATES AND TWELVE OF
THOSE BAN ABORTIONS. THINK ABOUT
THAT MEMBERS. I SINCE THE DAY I
COULD BEAR CHILDREN THROUGH THE
JOURNEY TO BECOME A MOTHER HAVE
NEVER QUESTIONS WHETHER I WOULD
MAKE THIS A DECISION ABOUT WHEN
AND IF I WOULD GET A REMAIN
PREGNANT. I ALWAYS DREAMT OF
BEING A MOTHER. BUT MY JOURNEY
TO MOTHERHOOD LIKE MANY WASN'T
EASY I HAD THREE COMPLICATED
PREGNANCIES BUT AS THE WHITE
PRIVILEGE WOMAN WITH AMAZING
HEALTH CARE I HAD A PROVIDER WHO
ALONG EVERY STEP OF THE JOURNEY
INSURED I KNEW IT WAS MY CHOICE
WHAT WE WOULD DO. THAT SHE WOULD
BE THERE FOR ME AND THAT WE
WOULD MAKE THAT DECISION
TOGETHER AND ALONE. AND I AM
BLESSED NOW WITH THREE BEAUTIFUL
CHILDREN. BUT I WAS ALSO BLESSED
WITH THE ECONOMY TO MAKE THAT
DECISION FOR MYSELF. AND AS I
LOOK IN MY DAUGHTER'S EYES. AND
I THINK ABOUT WHETHER SHE WILL
HAVE THAT SAME RIGHT TO DECIDE
HER OWN FUTURE MAY DEPEND ON
WHERE SHE LIVES SOME DAY. IT
MAKES ME SAD AND ANGRY AND A LOT
MORE WORDS THAT ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR THIS GREEN
CARPET. BUT SO TODAY I WANT TO
HONOR THE WORK THAT LED TO ROE
V. WADE GAVE WOMEN THAT RIGHT
THAT I HAVE ENJOYED MY ENTIRE
LIFE. BUT I ALSO ASK YOU TO LOOK
TO THE FUTURE AND WHAT YOUR ROLE
IS IN THAT FUTURE. FOR EVERY
GIRL AND EVERY WOMAN AND EVERY
PERSON WHO MAY BECOME PREGNANT.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO TO
STAND UP FOR THE ECONOMY THE
EQUITY THAT WOMEN HAVE FOUGHT SO
HARD FOR. THE GAINS WE HAVE
ACHIEVED THAT ARE NOW ON THE
LINE AS WE LOOK AT ROE V. WADE.
NO LONGER BEING INTACT NEXT YEAR
AT THIS TIME. I WHEN I THINK MY
CO AUTHORS ON THIS RESOLUTION
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. AND IT'S ALL
OF YOU WHO FIGHT ALONGSIDE ALL
OF US WHO STAND UP FOR WOMEN IN
REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE. BECAUSE NOT
ONE OF US CAN DO THIS ALONE BUT
TOGETHER WE CAN ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA REMAINS A BEACON OF
HOPE FOR WOMEN. BECAUSE WHAT IS
ON THE LINE IS NOT ONLY OUR
EQUITY OUR INTEGRITY AND OUR
INDEPENDENCE. BUT THE SAFETY AND
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF WOMEN
WHO WILL MAKE THIS DECISION NO
MATTER WHAT THE LAW SAYS. THANK
YOU MISTER CAN. IS A MEMBER
GARCIA RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
SEVENTY EIGHT ARE COMMEMORATING
THE FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
DECISION IN ROE VERSUS WADE
AFFIRMING EVERY INDIVIDUAL HAS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO CONTROL
THEIR OWN REPRODUCTIVE
DECISIONS. AND WHETHER TO
CONTINUE YOUR PREGNANCY OR
OBTAIN AN ABORTION. IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE PRIOR TO ROE VERSUS
WADE DECISION LACK OF ACCESS TO
SAFE AND LEGAL ABORTION BECAUSE
PREGNANT PEOPLE THEIR HEALTH AND
THEIR LIVES. THE COUNTING
APPROXIMATELY 70% OF ALL
REPORTED THAT TO TREATED TO
PREGNANCY AND CHILDBIRTH. AND
MANY WERE SEVERELY INJURED AS A
RESULT OF UNSAFE ABORTION
PROCEDURES. RIVER SURVEYS WITH A
VICTORY FOR PEOPLE TO OWN THEIR
OWN BODIES AND LAID THE
GROUNDWORK FOR THE REPRODUCTIVE
AND SEXUAL HEALTH CARE POLICIES.
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. BUT
TODAY IT'S BEING CHALLENGED IN
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT.
AND AT RISK OF BEING TURNED OR
SEVERELY ERODED. THROUGHOUT MY
COLLEGE EDUCATION I WAS ON BIRTH
CONTROL. I PURSUED MY STUDIES I
HAD TO RELY ON IT. BECAUSE OF
PRIVACY COULD HAVE MEANT THAT
THE MY STRUGGLE TO ACHIEVE I'M
LUCKY THAT I HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE ARE TO POTENTIAL INVEST
OUR SCHOOLS- HEALTH CENTER. I
PERSONALLY KNOW FROM STATISTICS
FROM MY HOMETOWN THAT THE
STRUGGLE ESPECIALLY SEVERE FOR
WOMEN OF COLOR. MY OWN ALMA
MATER BILL CLINTON SAY SCHOOL
HAD AND STILL HAS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST TEEN PREGNANCY RATES IN
CALIFORNIA. I REFUSE TO BE THAT
THE STATISTICS AND I DON'T WANT
THAT FOR OTHER WOMEN. TOO MANY
YOUNG WOMEN AND GIRLS BECOME
PREGNANT. NOT BECAUSE THEY
CHOOSE OF A BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
NIGHTS ALSO PREVENTS IT.
ABSTINENCE IS NOT A FULL IT'S AN
UNREALISTIC AND DANGEROUS
EXPERIMENTS. EVERYONE SHOULD
HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE. AND
YET WOMEN OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS.
LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO IDENTIFY. OF THE
DENNY'S INTERSECT AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
RESTRICTIONS ON THAT CARE. FOUR
IF I HADN'T GONE TO COLLEGE I
WOULD HAVE HAD ACCESS TO ANY
LIKE HER ON EITHER OR THAT WE
CONTROL THAT ALLOWED ME TO
CONTINUE MY STUDIES THIS IS A
REALITY FOR A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
BACK HOME FOR ME. FOR MANY THE
LACK OF ACCESS COULD BE DUE TO
SOCIAL STRUCTURAL FACTORS SUCH
AS FEWER NEIGHBORHOOD HEALTH.
SERVICES LESS INSURANCE COVERAGE
INCREASED ACCESS TO EDUCATIONAL
AND ECONOMIC ATTAINMENT. EVEN
PRACTICED ON OVER FACTORS SUCH
AS RACIAL BIAS AND STEREOTYPING
. THE FIGHT IS NOT JUST ABOUT A
PERSON'S RIGHT TO CONTROL THEIR
OWN DESTINY WHATEVER INSURING
THAT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS IT'S
ABOUT EQUITY. THE REALITY IS
THAT IN THOSE STATES WHERE THIS
IS BEING CHALLENGED AND PROBABLY
GOING TO BE OVERTURNED. IF YOU
HAVE THE MEANS YOU'RE GOING TO
FIND THE HEALTH CARE THAT YOU
NEED IT'S EVERYONE ELSE THAT'S
GOING TO BE LEFT BEHIND
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE THAT ARE
GOING TO BE LEFT BEHIND. H. R.
SEVENTY EIGHT SOLIDIFIES THE
ASSEMBLY SUPPORTING COMMITMENT
TO PROTECT THE PERSON
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT. TO SAID IF
AND WHEN THEY BECOME PREGNANT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHATEVER YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. GOOD
MORNING MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
THIS MORNING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF HR SEVENTY EIGHT THAT MARKS
THE FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT'S LANDMARK DECISION ROE V.
WADE. THIS SHOULD BE A TIME OF
CELEBRATION. CELEBRATING THE
FACT HE NINE YEARS AGO WE AFFIRM
THAT EVERYONE HAS THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO CONTROL
THEIR OWN REPRODUCTIVE DECISION
. FORTY NINE YEARS AGO WE AFFIRM
THAT THE DECISION TO CONTINUE OR
NOT CONTINUE A PREGNANCY IS
SACRED. PERSONAL AND SHOULD NOT
BE MADE FOR A WOMAN BY LAWYERS
NOR POLITICIANS. FORTY NINE
YEARS AGO WE AFFIRMED THAT
REGARDLESS OF YOUR RACE OR SOCIO
ECONOMIC STATUS THAT ALL WOMEN
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS THE SAME
ACCESS AND OPTIONS FOR THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT AND CELEBRATION
OF THE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS BE
MADE FORTY NINE YEARS AGO. IS
BEING OVERSHADOWED BY THE VERY
REAL AND SERIOUS THREAT OF IT
BEING OVERTURNED BY THE SUPREME
COURT. LEAVING AT LEAST THIRTY
SIX MILLION WOMEN NEARLY HALF
WOMEN OF REPRODUCTIVE AGE IN THE
UNITED STATES. ACROSS TWENTY SIX
STATES. WITHOUT ACCESS TO
ABORTION. AS AN OBGYN I HAVE
COUNSELED AND MANAGED MANY
PATIENTS WITH INTENDED AND
UNINTENDED PREGNANCIES. THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO CONTINUE WITH THE
PREGNANCY AND THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO TERMINATE THEIR PREGNANCY.
AND I CAN TELL YOU. THESE
DECISIONS ARE NEVER EASY FOR ANY
WOMAN. BUT THE REALITY IS THAT
IT IS HER BODY AND HER CHOICE.
BEFORE I MOVED BACK TO THIS
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I WAS
ACTUALLY PRACTICING IN TEXAS.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I LEFT IS
BECAUSE AS A REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
PHYSICIAN AND A WOMAN. WHOSE
HARD TO PRACTICE IN THE STATE.
THAT DID NOT RESPECT OUR
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND WAS
CONSTANTLY SWIPING STRIPPING
AWAY OUR ACCESS AND OUR POWER
OUR OWN BODIES. WE ARE LOOKING
IN CALIFORNIA THAT DESPITE WHAT
THE SUPREME COURT MAY DO WE WILL
STAY STEADFAST TO THE
AFFIRMATIONS WE MADE AS A
COUNTRY FORTY NINE YEARS AGO.
BUT WE MUST NOT FORGET ABOUT
THOSE WOMEN WHO LIVE IN THE
TWENTY SIX STATES THAT MAY SOON
LOSE THEIR RIGHTS TO EASILY
ACCESS SAFE AND LEGAL ABORTION.
IN A TIME WHERE WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
EQUALITY AND EQUITY AND HEALTH
CARE. WE MUST ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT INCLUDES ACCESS TO LEGAL
ABORTION. WITH TRAINED
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND SAFE
CLEAN HEALTHCARE FACILITIES. AS
OUR LEGISLATIVE BODY CELEBRATES
THE FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF
ROE V. WADE. I HOPE THAT WE
WOULD ALL RECOGNIZE THAT NOW IS
THE TIME TO READ THAT OURSELVES
TO ENSURING THAT ALL INDIVIDUALS
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE THEY
NEED INCLUDING ABORTION SERVICES
. EQUITY IN ACCESS TO CARE IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO ACHIEVING
POSITIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES. AND I
AM DEEPLY COMMITTED TO EXPANDING
ACCESS TO CARE AND PROTECTING
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM. I URGE AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR WEBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- LIKE FROM SAN DIEGO-
NOT ONLY AS A MEMBER BUT ALSO AS
A PRACTITIONER IN THE SPACE AND
HER VOICE- AS AN OBGYN I THINK
IS CRITICAL ON THIS FLOOR. AND I
THINK YOU ALL KNOW I HAVE BEEN
VERY OPEN PUBLICLY ABOUT MY OWN
EXPERIENCES WITH ABORTION MY
FIRST FLOOR SPEECH WHEN I GOT TO
THE ASSEMBLY WAS ABOUT THE
ABORTION THAT I HAD WHEN I WAS
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD. AND I WAS
IN BETWEEN HOMES AND IN BETWEEN
JOBS AND HAD
PREGNANCY AND THE CARE THAT I
SOUGHT AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
WHAT THAT MEANT TO ME IN THE
FACT THAT THAT GAVE ME THE POWER
TO MAKE THE BEST DECISION FOR
MYSELF AND FOR MY LIFE. AND WHAT
THAT HAS LED TO. I ALSO SPOKE.
RECENTLY IN SEPTEMBER I TURNS
OUT I WAS PREGNANT. I DIDN'T
KNOW IT I STARTED HAVING PRETTY
SEVERE CRAMPING HEAVY BLEEDING.
I WAS ABLE TO GO TO THE DOCTOR
PRETTY QUICKLY BECAUSE WE ARE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND BECAUSE
I'M AFFORD HEALTH CARE. AND IN
ONE BREATH THE DOCTOR TOLD ME.
YOU'RE PREGNANT YOU'RE HAVING A
MISCARRIAGE. AND WE NEED TO DO A
DNC NOW. WHICH IS AN ABORTION I
NEEDED THAT CARE IMMEDIATELY TO
HELP STOP THE BLEEDING FROM WHAT
WAS HAPPENING. AND I SPEAK
OPENLY AND PUBLICLY ABOUT THESE
EXPERIENCES BECAUSE IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON ALL OF US NOW IN
THIS MOMENT IN TIME IN THIS
COUNTRY TO USE OUR VOICE TO
SPEAK OUT ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING ACROSS THIS COUNTRY. I
GREW UP IN A TIME WHEN. I
THOUGHT THIS DECISION HAD BEEN
MADE FOR US. MY MOTHER AND MY
GRANDMOTHER IN THE GENERATIONS
BEFORE US HAD FOUGHT SO HARD TO
ENSURE. THAT I HAD THE ABILITY
TO MAKE THESE CHOICES FOR MYSELF
TO MAKE THE BEST DECISION FOR MY
LIFE. BUT YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS
HAPPENING ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
AND THE RIGHTS THAT ARE BEING
ERODED AWAY. AND IT IS NOT OKAY.
AND SO WHILE YOU KNOW SOME SOME
OF US ON THE FLOOR SO IT'S A
RESOLUTION IS NON BINDING. ARE
THESE THINGS JUST SYMBOLIC. ALL
RIGHT NOW IT MEANS MORE THAN
JUST A RESOLUTION IT MEANS THE
DECLARATION OF OUR VALUES AS A
STATE THAT WE ARE STANDING UP.
AND SUPPORTING PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO
DECIDE WHAT IS BEST FOR THEIR
LIFE. SO THAT'S WHY I FEEL
INCOME TO SPEAK TODAY TWICE
SPEAK OUT ON THIS ISSUE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY I CAN. BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO SEND THIS MESSAGE TO THE
REST OF THIS COUNTRY THAT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. WE CARE ABOUT
PEOPLE MAKING THE BEST DECISION
FOR THEMSELVES THAT WE EMPOWER
PEOPLE TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
AND I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE. I URGE
THAT YOU ALL STAND UP. WITH
PEOPLE ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND
SAY. NOT NOW. NOT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE STAND UP FOR
PEOPLE FOR WHAT THEY BELIEVE IN
THE BUILDING TO MAKE THEIR
CHOICES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS WICKS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA YOUR
RECOGNIZING YOUR DESK. THANK YOU
SO MUCH COLLEAGUES I ALSO URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS AND THANK
YOU TO MY SISTER COLLEAGUES FOR
SPEAKING THEIR TRUTH IN THIS
MOMENT. I FOUND MYSELF AT
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD STANDING WITH
MY MOTHER. IN WASHINGTON DC
LEARNING HOW TO PROTEST. FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS THE PHONE. AND
HAVE FULL OWNERSHIP DESPITE
GOVERNMENT OVER THEIR BODIES. WE
STOOD THERE I LEARNED TO PROTEST
I LEARNED TO RECOGNIZE THAT MY
BODY WAS MY BODY AND NOT THE
GOVERNMENT. I SAY THIS AS A
BLACK LATIN AS A PORTER RICAN
WHO HAD THE U. S. LITERALLY.
THEIR ALLIES ARE WOMEN. WE STOOD
THERE I WAS PROUD I WAS PROUD OF
THE PEOPLE THAT CAME TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD STAND
FOR ROBI WAY. I FOUND MYSELF
FIVE YEARS LATER LOOKING UP AT
THE CEILING. WITH A DOCTOR
HOLDING MY HANDS. AND TELLING ME
THAT I WAS ABOUT TO GO THROUGH A
PROCEDURE THAT WOULD HURT BUT
THAT WAS BY CHOICE ALONE. AT
TWENTY ONE. JUST HAVING
GRADUATED. FROM YALE COLLEGE
BREAKING THE POP OF THE POVERTY
CYCLEFOR NOT ONLY MY IMMEDIATE
FAMILY FOR THE ENTIRE FAMILY.
BOB MYSELF HAVING TO MAKE A
CHOICE. BETWEEN BEING ABLE TO
HAVE ECONOMIC SECURITY. AND A
PATHWAY TO BE ABLE TO GET A JOB
WITH A DEGREE THAT I HAD JUST
GOTTEN. OR SOMETHING ELSE AND
PUTTING ANOTHER BURDEN ON MY
MOTHER OF A DIFFERENT SORT. AND
SO I MADE THE CHOICE TO SEEK AN
ABORTION. THAT PREGNANCY WAS ONE
OF SEVEN. I HAD THREE
MISCARRIAGES AND I HAVE THREE
BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN. AND I'M
THANKFUL FOR THE MEDICAL CARE
SINCE SYSTEM THAT I WAS ABLE TO
SEEK IN CONNECTICUT M. IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH ALLOWED ME TO
BE SECURE THAT I WOULDN'T BE
CRIMINALIZED FOR MY DECISIONS.
THAT WAY WOULDN'T BE
CRIMINALIZED FOR MY PREGNANCY
LOSS AND THAT I WOULD BE ABLE TO
HAVE ACCESS AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO
THE CARE THAT THEY NEEDED EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THOSE EXPERIENCES
. POLITICS I ASK YOU TO STAND IN
THIS MOMENT AND RECOGNIZE THE
CALIFORNIA IT LITERALLY. THE
LAST STAND FOR JUSTICE THE LAST
STAND FIRST ENSURING THAT BLACK
AND BROWN LEVINE AT API HOWEVER
YOU ARE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS THE CARE THAT THEY SO
DESERVE. THE LAST STAND TO
RECOGNIZE. THAT A WOMAN'S BODY
IS A WOMAN'S BODY. COLLEAGUES
THIS IS THE MOST CRITICAL
MOMENTS THAT WE ARE IN RIGHT
NOW. JUSTICE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IS NOT ON OUR SIDE AND WHEN I
SAY. CALIFORNIA IS A LAST STAND
I HOPE THAT YOU TAKE THAT AND
HEAR IT IN YOUR HEARTS. AND ACT
ACCORDINGLY IN SUPPORTING THIS
RESOLUTION AND EVERY SINGLE BILL
THAT WILL BE BROUGHT BEFORE YOU.
WITH MY SISTER ALLIES IN THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AS OUR TOP
PRIORITY SO RECOGNIZE. THAT HOW
WE GO THIS COUNTRY HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT ITSELF.
AS WOMEN IN DROVES WILL COME TO
CALIFORNIA THE SEA CARE WE NEED
TO BE THERE WITH THEM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN ADULT. THANK
YOU MISS BONTA. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO DISCUSS THE
MEASURE AS A MEMBER OF OUR
CANYON CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR SPEAKING SO
INCREDIBLY POWERFULLY ABOUT THIS
ISSUE AND THE IMPORTANCE
IMPORTANCE TO THE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THEY DON'T HAVE EQUITABLE
HEALTHCARE TODAY BUT CONTINUE TO
DESERVE ACCESS TO IT. I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR USING HER SKILLS AND
HER VOICE TO ENSURE THE WOMEN
UNDER HER CARE HAVE THIS CHOICE
. AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ALAMEDA AND
OAKLAND FOR TELLING THEIR
STORIES. BECAUSE THE TRUTH OF
THE MATTER IS THAT THE DECISION
. A ROE V. WADE. DID EXACTLY.
FOR WOMEN ACROSS THIS NATION
WHAT IT DID FOR COLLEAGUES. IT
GAVE THEM A CHOICE A CHOICE IN
WHAT THEIR FUTURE LOOKED LIKE.
AND SOME MAY HAVE CHOSEN TO
CONTINUE THE PREGNANCY AND SOME
MAY HAVE CHOSEN ABORTION. AND
EVERY ONE OF THOSE CHOICES
DESERVES THE RESPECT THAT ROE V.
WADE GRANTED IT. AND SO TODAY
LET US HONOR THAT DECISION AND
MOVING FORWARD LET'S CONTINUE TO
FIGHT FOR IT. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU MISTER CAN WOULD YOU
LIKE THE FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS. YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CAN THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS. ALL THOSE WHO WISH TO
BE A CO AUTHOR PLEASE REGISTER
YOUR VOTE. THERE ARE FORTY SIX
CO AUTHORS FORTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSING NAME
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. WE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS FIFTY ONE
THROUGH FIFTY THREE. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE UP THE SECOND
DAY CONSENT CALENDAR. THERE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONTENT
CALENDAR AND BEFORE WE VOTE WE
WILL FIRST TAKE A FILE ITEM
FIFTY EIGHT ON CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ADDING CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER CAN
RELATED TO MATERNAL HEALTH
AWARENESS DAY. CLERK WILL NOW
OPEN THE ROLE TO ALLOW ANY
MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR
TO THE RESUME. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS THE DESIRE
TO GO. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE FIFTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS
. MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER
WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL READ
THE SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE ONLINE BY SIMPLY MEMBERS OF
THE EDUARDO GARCIA AND OTHERS
RELATED TO EXTREME WEATHER.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT COUNTY. ARE THOSE. ALL
THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY VOTE EITHER SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. CLERK WILL
READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO. MEMBERS
WE HAVE ONE MORE ITEM. ON THE
AGENDA.
MEMBERS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE WE ARE TAKING
UP ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY SEVEN
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN YOU MAY
OPEN FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS
. KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY BLL TWO
FIFTY SEVEN WITH A MAMMOTH BY
SOMEONE MEMBER HOLDING SOME
MEMBER HOLDEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO AB TWO FIFTY SEVEN
THAT MAKE CLEAR FINE AND
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES TO CHANGE
AUTHORS AND ADDRESS CONCERNS
REGARDING THE LEGIT LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY OVER THE FAST COUNCIL
ESTABLISHED IN THIS BILL. I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
JOINT AND CO AUTHORS OF THIS
MEASURE FOR THEIR SUPPORT AND
CONTINUED ADVOCACY OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. I'VE BEEN AND
WILL CONTINUE AND REMAIN
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. AND MEMBERS TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS WITH THIS
MEASURE. I VALUE COLLABORATION
AND FEEDBACK AS PRINCIPLES THAT
ENABLE US TO PROVIDE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE FOR EVERYONE. AND THAT
IS PRECISELY THE OBJECTIVE OF
THIS BILL. I'VE LISTENED INTAKE
TO I'VE LISTENED AND TODAY
MAKING THE FOLLOWING SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENTS TO AB TWO FIVE SEVEN
. ONE REPLY TO THE COUNCIL DOES
NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO CREATE
OR AMEND STATUTES. TO CLARIFY
THAT NOTHING IN THE BILL IS
INTENDED TO USURP THE
LEGISLATURE'S AUTHORITY OVER
STANDARDS FOR FRANCHISES
FRANCHISE OWNERS FRANCHISEES AND
FRANCHISE WORKERS. ESTABLISH THE
COUNCIL WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
AND INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS.
REQUIRE THE COUNCIL TO REPORT
PROPOSED STANDARDS TO THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEES. UPON RECEIVING THE
REPORT THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE
SIXTY DAYS TO REPEAL OR AMEND
PROPOSED STANDARDS BEFORE BEING
ADOPTED AS REGULATIONS. REQUIRE
THE COUNCIL TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION EVERY THREE YEARS TO
THE LABOR COMMITTEES FOR JOINT
HEARING AND PERFORMANCE REVIEW.
THESE ARE IN DIRECT RESPONSE TO
MANY OF YOUR CONCERNS BUT AS
ALWAYS I WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
TIME FOR THOSE WHO APPROACH ME
WITH CONCERNS. OR SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
REWROTE. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN MR
FOR THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WE
WERE OBJECTIVISM ANCESTRAL CALL
THE- THANK YOU MISTER FLORA. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
AMENDMENT. MEMBERS THESE ARE ON
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL THOSE NOTES WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO THE. BURKE WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTES AYE AYES ARE FORTY THREE
KNOWS THIRTEEN ON THE AMENDMENTS
IMMINENCE ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON FILE. SENATOR READING FILE ITEM
FIFTY FOUR THREE FIFTY SIX SHALL
BE PASSED AND RETAINED. THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS IS
TAKE YOUR SEATS ORTEGA
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS A BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENT WE
WISH TO WISH WE WISH TO
RECOGNIZE AND WISH A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY
ARE TOO WERE CELEBRATING THE
BIRTHDAY IS TOMORROW. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS- TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN MEMORY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI YOUR RECOGNIZE YOUR
DOES FEAR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER. I
RISE TO HONOR A HERO. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FIREFIGHTER
JONATHAN FLAGLER. WHO ON JANUARY
SIXTH. DIED IN THE LINE OF DUTY
. SAVING A FAMILY FROM A FIRE IN
THEIR HOME. AND MYSELF A
COMMUNITY OF RANCHO PALOS VERDES
. AT AROUND TWO AM ON JANUARY
SIXTH. FIREFIGHTERS FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FIRE STATION
EIGHTY THREE AND RANCHO PALACE
VERDES RESPONDED TO THE CALL.
FIREFIGHTER FLAGLER ALONG WITH
HIS CREW SAFELY EVACUATED THE
FAMILY. BUT HE WAS OVERCOME BY
THE SMOKE. AND DIED FROM THE
INJURIES THAT HE SUFFERED IN THE
FIRE. TODAY FIREFIGHTERS
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES COUNTY AS
WELL AS THE STATE. ARE HONORING
JONATHAN FLAGLER. IN A COUNTY
WIDE FLAG CEREMONY. ACCORDING TO
HIS FELLOW FIREFIGHTERS.
JONATHAN LOVED HIS JOB BUT MORE
THAN THAT HE LOVED HIS WIFE
JENNY JOHNSON FLAGLER AND HE WAS
PROUD OF HIS TWO TEENAGE SONS
BRODY AND JACK. PLEASE AUTUMN
PLEASE JOIN ME. IN A DURING
TODAY'S SESSION IN THE MEMORY.
OF A HERO JONATHAN FLAGLER.
THANK YOU MISTER MERGING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WHEN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZING YOUR DESPERATE
GERMAN MEMORY. I THINK I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIS FOR SCHOOL
FOR SOME SORRY I PUT MY MIND TO.
THAT'S OKAY A SIMILAR DAVIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU. TODAY
I STAND BEFORE YOU TO HONOR A
HERO THAT PASSED AWAY IN JANUARY
SIXTH AT THE YOUNG AGE OF FORTY
SEVEN YEARS JONATHAN FLAGLER WAS
A ONSTITUENT IN MY DISTRICT.
LIVING IN SACRAMENTO WHERE HIS
WIFE JENNIFER AND TWO SONS WHO
SURVIVED HIM STILL RESIDE.
JONATHAN AEROBICALLY RESPONDED
TO A HOUSE FIRE ON TWO FIFTY AM
IN RANCHO PALOS VERDES OR HIS
TEAM OF FIREFIGHTERS WERE ABLE
TO RESCUE THE FAMILY. FROM THE
INSIDE THE BURNING HOME BUT
TRAGICALLY JOHNSON LOST HIS LIFE
IN THE EFFORT JONATHAN WAS A
TWENTY ONE YEAR OF. FIREFIGHTER
VETERANS SERVING NINETEEN YEARS
WITH THE VERNE FIRE DEPARTMENT
BEFORE TRANSITIONING TO THE L.
A. COUNTY. FIRE INTO OVER TWENTY
TWENTY IT WAS IT BUT IT HAPPENED
FATHER UNCLE FRIEND AND HERO I'M
GREATLY SADDENED BY THE STRATEGY
AND THE LOSS. OF A TRUE MAN
PLEASE KEEP HIM HIS FAMILY IN
YOUR PRAYERS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS DAVIS. DECEMBER WHEN
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
ALSO ASK THE REGION IN MEMORY OF
JONATHAN FLAGGER A SAN CLEMENTE.
IN THE EARLY MORNING HOURS OF
GENEROUS SIX TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO. LOS ANGELES COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT STATION EIGHTY THREE
LOST ONE OF ITS FINEST WHEN
JONATHAN PASSED AWAY. DUE TO
INJURIES SUFFERED A WISE RESPOND
TO HOUSE FIRE IN POSSIBILITIES.
THEN AS MEN WAS FORTY SEVEN. WAS
IT WHEN YEAR VETERAN OF THE FIRE
SERVICE BEGINNING IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO. HE WORKED FOR
THE CITY OF VERNON BEFORE
MERGING WITH THE- ANGELES COUNTY
FIRE DEPARTMENT TWENTY TWENTY.
HIS COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS WILL
REMEMBER HIM FONDLY AT A FAMILY
MAN. BUT A FANTASTIC SENSE OF
HUMOR WHO LOVED THE BEACH IT WAS
A COMMITTED AND DEDICATED. IN
HIS FOR. WE'RE SO PROUD. AMONG
US LIKE NOTHING. BUT WHAT'S YOUR
- FULL WELL THE RISKS BUT IT
ANYPLACE. HERE SURVIVED BY HIS
J. AND THEIR TWO TEENAGE SONS WE
SAID OUR AND THOUGHTS TO DO IT
IS DIFFICULT. WE ALSO OFFER OUR
CONDOLENCES TO THE STATION HOUSE
STATION EIGHTY THREE AND THE
BRAVE FIREFIGHTERS WHO SERVE
ALONGSIDE HIM. AND ALSO TO HIS
HOMETOWN SAN CLEMENTE WE ALL
MOURNED WITH JENNY AND TONS AND
THE COMMUNITY FOR JOHNSON'S LOSS
WE WILL BE HONORING HIM TOMAR IN
THE CITY OF LOS ALAMEDA IS FOR
HIS RENOWNED FUNERAL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THEIR RISE IN MEMORY OF
A GOOD FRIEND- FROM THE CITY OF
DELANO THAT'S HUBERT WINDOW
RANDALL. RABINAL HUBER WAS WORN
AND OAHU HAWAII ON NOVEMBER
THIRD NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT HIS
PARENTS OF AN DEAL AND
SIMPLICIO ROBIN ALL MOVED THEIR
FAMILY TO DELANO CALIFORNIA.
WHEN HUBER WAS ONLY TWO YEARS
OLD. AND DELAY KNOWS WERE HUMOR
WOULD BUILD HIS LASTING LEGACY.
HE WAS AN ALL STAR BASKETBALL
PLAYER AT DELAND HIGH SCHOOL AND
HE WENT ON TO PLAY FOR PORTABLE
COLLEGE AND CSU BAKERSFIELD'S.
MEN'S BASKETBALL TEAM IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE HE WAS
INVITED BY THE PHILIPPINE
GOVERNMENT TO TRAVEL TO THE
TEENS AND PLAY WITH SOME OF THE
GREATEST PLAYERS OF THE
PHILIPPINE BASKETBALL
ASSOCIATION. AND REPRESENT THE
LINE NOW AND IT'S FILIPINO
COMMUNITY. THAT SAME YEAR HE
MARRIED THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE
JANET. AND THE TWO BEGAN A
WONDERFUL LIFE TOGETHER. IT WAS
CLEAR TO EVERYONE HOW DEEP THEIR
LOVE WAS FOR EACH OTHER. AND
THEY SHARED THEIR LOVE WITH
THEIR SON ZACHARY AND DAUGHTER
TAYLOR. YOU WERE WORK HARD TO
PROVIDE FOR HIS FAMILY WORKING
HIS WAY FROM A PART TIME. TELLER
AT GIBRALTAR SAVINGS AND LOAN TO
EVENTUALLY BECOME THE VICE
PRESIDENT. OF THE LOCAL OFFICE
IN JUST A FEW YEARS. IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR YOU WERE BEGAN HIS
CAREER PUBLIC SERVICE WITH THE
CITY OF THE LABEL AND LATER WITH
CALIFORNIA DIRECT DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
IN. NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN YOU
WERE TRANSFERRED TO NORTH. NORTH
THE CURRENT STATE PRISON WHERE
YOU. UNTIL HIS RETIREMENT. IN
BUILT EVERLASTING BONDS WITH HIS
COLLEAGUES. IF YOU EVER NEEDED A
FIVE YEAR BURKE ODDS WERE THAT
HE WAS WORKING AT ANY ONE OF THE
DOZENS LOCAL LOCAL EVENTS AND
PROGRAMS THEY SERVED IN THE
LIONEL HE WAS PRESIDENT OF THE
GREATER DELANO AREA YOUTH
FOUNDATION. A MEMBER OF THE
LANDAL PARKSAND RECREATION
COMMISSION BOARD AND MANAGER AND
COACH FOR THE DELAY IN A LITTLE
LEAGUE BASEBALL TEAMS A LIFETIME
MEMBER OF THE DELAYED HARVEST
HOLIDAYS- COMMITTEE AND AN
AUDITOR AND MEMBER OF THE
FILIPINO. COMMUNITY OF DELANO.
HE NINETY NINE HE WAS HONORED AS
THE PHILIPPINE WE CAN GRAND
MARSHALL FOR THE FIRST
PHILIPPINE WEEKEND TOURNAMENT
CHAMPION BASKETBALL TEAM- THE
BLACK MAGIC. HE WAS PRESIDENT OF
THE DELANO CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
DIRECTOR OF THE DELANO.
PHILIPPINE WEEKEND COMMUNITY
COMMITTEE AND INCREDIBLE ACTIVE
MEMBER OF ST MARY OF THE
MIRACULOUS MEDAL CATHOLIC
CHURCH. AND HE SERVED ON THE
LAN- UNION. ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
BOARD. OF TRUSTEES FOR SEVENTEEN
YEARS. YOU KNOW THIS IS JUST TO
NAME A FEW OF THE THINGS HE'S
DONE HE WAS HONORED AS A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FILIPINO WEEKEND GRAND
MARSHAL ALONG WITH HIS WIFE
JANET. AND THE RECEIVE THE TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO DELANO CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE THE MAN OF THE YEAR
AWARD. AS WELL AS IN TWENTY
TWELVE. THE FILIPINO COMMUNITY
OF DELANO MAN OF THE YEAR AWARD
. IF YOU DIDN'T SEE HUMOR TO ANY
ONE OF THESE SPOTS YOU CAN FIND
THEM EASILY BY JUST LISTENING
FOR HIS LAUGH. HE LOVED TO TELL
JOKES PULL PRANKS. AND MAKE HIS
NIECES AND NEPHEWS GIGGLE. AS
OTHER LEVELS TRAVEL. ESPECIALLY
TO DISNEYLAND IS FAVORITE PLACE
TO BE WITH THE FAMILY. YOU KNOW
IF YOU EVER PASSED ON DECEMBER
SEVENTH. SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT HOME SURROUNDED BY HIS
FAMILY. HIS MEMORY WILL BE
CHERISHED BY JANET HIS WIFE OF
FORTY TWO YEARS THE SUN'S
ACTIVITY HIS DAUGHTER TAYLOR. AS
MOTHERS SIMPLY SEE A RABBIT ALL
HIS BROTHER JESSE WRAPPING ALL.
THE SISTERS DARLENE MARTIN AND
MILLIE DARK. ALONG WITH HIS
NEPHEWS NIECES GREAT NEPHEWS
NIECES COUSINS AND- LIFELONG
FRIENDS. AT MEMBERS I CAN TELL
YOU SHIVER WAS A PERSONAL FRIEND
HE WAS SOMEBODY- WHEN I FIRST
STARTED MY POLITICAL CAREER WAS.
NOT- INCREDIBLY HELPFUL IN
MAKING SURE CONNECTED WITH
EVERYBODY BUT HE WAS ONE OF THE
GENTLEMEN. THAT GENUINELY HAD A
GOOD HEART FOR THE COMMUNITY
WANTED TO DO WHAT WAS RIGHT. AND
YOU KNOW HE LOVES THE HE WAS
JUST A JOY TO BE AROUND BECAUSE
HE LOVED IT NOT ONLY PULL PRANKS
THAT. AND MAKE EVERYBODY LAUGH
BUT HE WENT OUT OF HIS WAY TO
MAKE YOU FEEL SPECIAL. I THINK
THAT'S WHY SO MANY PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY WILL. WERE SO SADDENED
TO HEAR OF HIS LOSS AND WE WILL
LIVE FOREVER BE. INDEBTED TO NOT
ONLY HIS SERVICE TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY BUT JUST THE WAY HE
MADE PEOPLE FEEL. AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK OF THIS BODY TO
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SALAS. SOME MIRABELLA
THERE IS YOUR RECOGNIZED YOUR
DESK FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF BARBARA JOYCE
MASALA WHO PASSED AWAY
PEACEFULLY SURROUNDED BY HER
FAMILY ON DECEMBER ELEVENTH
FOLLOWING A LONG BATTLE WITH
BREAST CANCER. BARBER IS A
MOTHER. OF A COMMUNITY LEADER
AND VERY DEAR FRIEND OF MINE
JOHN RISALA AND I AM SO SORRY
FOR HIS FAMILY'S LOSS. BARBER
WAS BORN IN EUGENE OREGON IN
NINETEEN FORTY SIX SHE ATTENDED
WASHINGTON STATE UNIVERSITY
WHERE SHE WAS A MEMBER OF THE
KAPPA DELTA SORORITY. GRADUATING
IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT WITH A
DEGREE IN ECONOMICS. FOLLOWING
GRADUATION BARBARA MOVED TO LOS
ANGELES TO ACCEPT A POSITION
WITH SECURITY PACIFIC NATIONAL
BANK. WHERE SHE BECAME ONE OF
THE FIRST WOMEN ADMITTED TO THE
BANK'S MANAGEMENT TRAINING
PROGRAM. IT WAS THERE AT THE
BANK WHERE SHE MET THE LOVE OF
HER LIFE RICHARD MASALA. THEY
MARRIED AND THE TWO SETTLED IN
WESTCHESTER CALIFORNIA WHERE
THEY LIVED FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS.
THEY HAD TWO CHILDREN STEPHANIE
AND JOHN. DURING HER
PROFESSIONAL CAREER BARBOUR WORK
FOR BOTH SECURITY PACIFIC
NATIONAL BANK AND BANK OF
AMERICA. BARBER GAVE HER TIME TO
SELFLESSLY HELPING OTHERS
THROUGH CAUSES SHE WAS
PASSIONATE ABOUT. SHE SERVED AS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BOB HOPE USL WHICH HELPS SUPPORT
OUR NATION'S ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICEMEMBERS. HE SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
WESTCHESTER SCRIPPS STREET SCAPE
IMPROVEMENT ASSOCIATION HELPING
TO SECURE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR LANDSCAPE IMPROVEMENTS ALONG
SEPULVEDA BOULEVARD. THROUGH
WESTCHESTER WHICH SERVES AS THE
GATEWAY FROM LOS ANGELES TO LA
ACTS. BARBER PLAYED AN ACTIVE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING WHICH
COLLABORATED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO ASSIST VICTIMS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING. FORMER
CONTRIBUTIONS SHE WAS DESIGNATED
AS AN HONORARY ROTARIAN AND
RECOGNIZED AS A ROTARY PAUL
HARRIS FELLOW. BARBARA ALSO
SERVED ON THE WASHINGTON STATE
UNIVERSITY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL. SHE AND HER
HUSBAND AND OUT A SCHOLARSHIP IN
THEIR NAME TO HELP PROVIDE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR WSA WSU
FRESHMAN STUDENTS FROM
CALIFORNIA. BARBARA IS SURVIVED
BY HER HUSBAND OF MORE THAN HALF
A CENTURY RICHARD MASALA HER
SISTER ARLENE NICHOLS FOR
CHILDREN STEPHANIE AND JOHN AND
FOUR GRANDCHILDREN TIMOTHY TYLER
THOMAS AND MACY SMEDLEY.
BARBARA'S LIFE AND LEGACY ARE AN
EXAMPLE WE SHOULD ALL STRIVE TO
FOLLOW MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WITHDRAWN IN THE MEMORY
OF BARBARA JOYCE MASALA. THANK
YOU MISTER ROGERS MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DOES TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS I AM ORDERING THE
TEST TO BE HELD OPEN TO RECEIVE
COMMITTEE REPORTS. AND THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WILL
MEET UPON A GERMAN TODAY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- TO. THE SERGEANTS
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIRST NO SESSION
NO CHECK IN. MONDAY JANUARY
TWENTY FOURTH FLOOR SESSION AT
ONE PM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED IN
BETWEEN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER SALAS MOVES AND MISTER.
LEVINE SECONDS AT THE HEALTH
CENTER AND UNTIL MONDAY JANUARY
TWENTY FOURTH AT ONE PM.